[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon joueur mais petit ami j'espère que
vous êtes tous de bonne humeur ce soir
pluvieux dans mon patron bravo c'est ce
qu'il faut avoir toujours le sourire et
ne jamais boudé comme nounours je suis
toujours content même quand nicolas et
pimprenelle me font des niches non les
châles propos
[Musique]
bonsoir et en font sa main oui c'est une
belle chanson de 3,7 walla charmant
seigneur de nous si bien les animaux
ces freins de la route
vive le chameau
perdez dans le désert climats anciens ya
mort qui nettoie doit doit doit divine
la preuve il en est j'ai enfin de dodo
dodo des doutes sérieux de la bonté de
dieu
himalaya jacques allez allez allez allez
[Musique]
où il s'est fait rembarrer verra aussi
les rageux nounou blues les bayous tunes
aussi léger canin d'un temps qui passe
donne d'autres cieux fermer les yeux
ouverts c'est simple un de désert
himalayens java calcutta signe marina
himalaya java calcutta sidi bas rhinois
les allées à bavay
allez allez allez à bombay ont fait un
mort et neuf et bien mais chamoun
nounours il est fatigué il va au lit lui
aussi naizain déjà nenê vous en avez de
la chance
là j'ai pas la leur
bonne nuit le petit
donne une annonce à demain elle était
très jolie cette chanson bravo très joli
mais un peu fatigante g2c soif pas trop
patience nounours fait comme les
chameaux je ne suis pas un chapeau je
suis un loup l'ours en route nounours 28
les enfants fait deux pour un
ve
e
[Musique]
où
à
hamon
[Musique]